can't help but smile when talking about
john madden jim nance joins us right now
jim good morning how are you doing
yeah good morning nate obviously all of
us that new coach madden are feeling
very blue uh at this point
just a couple of days ago i know you're
aware of it there was a documentary on
his life that was amazing it was as if
you were watching eulogy and the thing
just two and a half days later he was
gone unexpectedly it's hard to get your
mind around that
the nfl called madden legendary
commissioner roger goodell said he was
football how will you remember john
madden
i think that's a pretty good place to
start you know i had a very close tie
with with roger and and the commissioner
sought his counsel on a lot of issues
that were going around the league far
after he left the broadcast booth up
until uh this year
and
you know there was i was watching with
my
the children of christmas movie called
the boy
who was christmas
and i was thinking
overnight that john was the man who was
football at so many different levels as
the player who got drafted by the way by
the philadelphia eagles as a legendary
coach which is how he wanted to go into
the hall of fame as a coach
as a broadcaster as celebrated as any
sports analyst has ever been or ever
will be uh the video game which will
live on for generations to come which
popularized the sport for millions of
people i mean he touched a lot of lives
you know i just i think what everybody
will remember about him he's so
authentic and he brought so much joy and
enthusiasm to the game whether it was
coaching or broadcasting younger people
knew him from video games what do you
think his real legacy will be i love
that he said that his dad said once you
start working you're gonna have to work
the rest of his your life and he said i
never worked a day in my life and he
felt that way about all of these
different professions that he went
through what do you think his legacy
will be
well everything he touched was gold and
that's why he's wearing a gold jacket in
canton ohio but you know the players the
young players today think that madden is
a video game and then they don't realize
that he was this enormous
talent in broadcasting for 30 years
starting at cbs working half of his
career at our network and still so many
friends from producers and technicians
to broadcasters still remain at cbs who
were influenced by john and then you go
back to that coaching career i mean
there's a lot of different things that
he did and he accomplished them all at a
very high level but his legacy i think
more than anything is he was he was a
man of the people he could relate to
everyone
and uh he had time for people as he
traversed his country on the madden
cruiser because you know he wouldn't fly
he loved stopping
america and getting to know people and
spending time with them stopping at a
at a diner and you know just name it all
50 states he toured this country the
bases and had time for people people
loved him
yeah
jim it's vlad uh let's talk about his
legacy as a coach it's one of the things
that you pointed out that he wanted to
go into the hall of fame for
this oakland team that he coached in the
1970s was a powerhouse and that's saying
a lot when you're talking about teams
from pittsburgh and dallas that people
remember from that era what made him
such an incredible coach
well good for you vlad you you mentioned
a couple things i was going to point out
i mean he was coaching at a time when
chuck noll was winning super bowls for
pittsburgh uh tom landry was at davos
don schultz in miami his career started
hank strahan was in his division at
kansas city he got the head coaching job
when he was 32 he retired when he was
42. he won 103 games in 10 years that's
an incredible record will still has the
all-time winning percentage best winning
percentage for any coach that won 100
games so it was short as far as a career
it was highly successful and i'm sure it
was successful because of the things
that we saw later on as a broadcaster he
knew about nuance and he knew about
people he loved x's and o's and teaching
and he loved being able to try to teach
people to make them better
yeah as we've been saying uh he changed
the game sure did and especially made it
accessible to people all around the
world that's a video game jim nance
always great to talk to you my friend
thank you for sharing your thoughts on
the legacy of john madden we appreciate
it
thank you for allowing me the chance to
talk about one of the great people that
anybody whoever met him would all agree
one of the great people were met in
their lives
absolutely thank you jim